-I love the movie "Parasite."
It is one of the best films
of the year.
You directed it and co-wrote
this film.
I went in not knowing
what the movie was about
and just heard buzz
that this was great.
And I loved it.
I loved it, because -- I don't
want to spoil anything.
-Yeah.
-It's hard to describe
the movie.
-Yeah.
How do you describe
"Parasite"?
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-I'd like to say
as little as possible here,
because the film is best when
you go into the cold.
[ Light laughter ]
-Anyway --
Well, this is a talk show.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, you have to say
something.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-It's a story
about a family.
The son goes into a rich house
as a tutor
and the story unfolds
from there.
-Just knock out performance.
You just -- oh.
You feel sad for them, and then
they make you laugh.
-Yeah.
-And then they're in trouble.
And you go, "Oh -- Oh, don't.
This is bad."
I mean, seriously, that you go
through all of these --
-Yeah.
-And then that's just the first,
kind of, half.
-They're all very human.
Yeah. It's just funny
and scary movie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
"Parasite" won the grand prize,
the Palme d'Or
at the Cannes Film Festival.
This is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was the first --
It was the first Korean film
to receive the award.
And you were the first Korean
director to win the award.
Congratulations on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's what made me laugh.
I read that it got an
eight-minute standing ovation
for the film.
-Yeah.
-Eight minutes of people
clapping.
And then you got up and all you
said was,
"Thank you.
Let's all go home."
[ Laughter ]
What happened?
Why?
-'Cause actually the screening
was very late night,
it was almost midnight and --
[ Speaking Korean ]
-So the standing ovation
lasted very long.
But the actors and I
were very hungry,
because we couldn't eat dinner.
[ Laughter ]
-So, actually,
me and the actors --
[ Speaking Korean ]
"I'm so hungry."
-We all were saying to each
other, "We're so hungry."
And they ended up subtitling it
in the video that was later.
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-But applause never stopped.
So, finally I said,
"Let's go home."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think that's great.